ça piquait ce matin au moment de mettre
le nez dehors le gel refait son
apparition en val de loire une période
toujours redoutée par les vignerons et
les arboriculteurs qui dispose de toute
une panoplie pour protéger les bourgeons
du froid aspersion tour antigel mais
aussi bougies et hélicoptères parfois
même les deux une méthode qui a fait ses
preuves comme a pu le constater audrey
champigny à montlouis sur loire
dès 7h ce matin avant le lever du jour
les premiers passages de l'hélicoptère
au dessus des vignes de vol à gré à
montlouis des feux de paille et de bois
par ci par là et de grandes bougies
milieu des rangs pour réchauffer les
lignes et ainsi éviter le gel des
bourgeons ya deux procès s'il ya un
procès ou avec lequel on joue avec la
version de température c'est à dire
qu'il fait plus chaud au combat donc on
aspire l'air chaud mais ce matin il
n'avait pas donc on a fait beaucoup de
ce matin pour justement la deuxième
solution pour jouer avec le feu donc on
rabat les fumées on attise le feu et on
mélange tout ça dans les vignes avec des
températures matinales qui frôle les -3
degrés depuis ces derniers jours
l'urgence est désormais de préserver au
maximum la récolte 2021
on ne vais pas le faire cette année et
en fait on s'est décidé hier parce qu'on
a les parcelles qu'on n'a pas protégé
hier
on a perdu déjà pas mal de bourgeons on
s'est fait avoir comme des bleus en fait
la température elle a chuté
on a perdu deux degrés en un quart
d'heure quand après 1h15 de survol des 6
hectares de vignes et une vérification
minute par minute
verdict j'ai des thermos matin dans les
vignes descendre et je vois que les
températures au sol remonte on gagne un
degré demi à deux degrés sur les
parcelles hélico et les bougies les
bougies ça limite la casse alors c'est
pas facile de dire mais à un degré 1° me
déjà en 2017 et 2019 bertrand élise
avait dû faire appel à un hélicoptère
pour lutter contre les jeux les dans
leurs vignes
une opération qui a un coût entre 2500
et 3000 euros